aquí
[Música]
el partido liberal de jeaustin crudo
ganó las elecciones de canadá pero no
logró la mayoría absoluta por lo que
deberá formar coalición para poder
gobernar los votantes eligieron
anticipadamente a 338 congresistas la
llamada crisis de los submarinos que ha
enfrentado a francia con eeuu y
australia de escalo en el marco de la
asamblea general de naciones unidas el
ministro de exteriores francés jean yves
le drian pidió explicaciones a estados
unidos en nueva york'
y estas imágenes de oficiales
fronterizos estadounidenses
presuntamente usando látigos contra los
migrantes haitianos en la frontera sur
generan indignación la casa blanca
lamentó el hecho pero prosiguió con las
deportaciones cientos ya regresaron a
puerto principal
muy buenos días para todos bienvenidos a
las noticias en france 24 cierro a
blanco como siempre un gusto
acompañarlos comenzamos con una noticia
en sudán el ejército frustró un intento
de golpe de estado según informaron la
radio y la televisión oficial un miembro
del gobernante de consejo soberano en el
poder como parte de una frágil acuerdo
de transición entre militares y civiles
iniciado tras el derrocamiento de omar
al bachir en 2019 aseguró que la
situación está bajo control
y vamos ahora hasta canadá donde el
partido del actual primer ministro dio
sin trudeau venció en las elecciones
anticipadas que se celebraron ayer sin
embargo no logró la esperada mayoría
absoluta y tendrá que volver a formar
una coalición
una apuesta que estuvo a punto de salir
mal cuando justin trudeau subió a la
tarima el lunes por la noche fue para
celebrar pero la victoria de su partido
liberal fue agridulce no obtuvieron la
mayoría absoluta que esperaban después
de que los votantes expresaron su enfado
por el hecho de que crudo hubiera
convocado unos comicios anticipados en
medio de una pandemia
[Aplausos]
los escucho cuando dicen que solo
quieren volver a las cosas que les
gustan no preocuparse por esta pandemia
o por las elecciones que sólo quieren
saber que sus parlamentarios les
cubrirán la espalda durante esta crisis
y más allá
jones cuando justin crudo convocó las
elecciones con dos años de antelación
apostó a que los canadienses no
elegirían un gobierno conservador en
medio de la crisis pero la campaña se
tornó rápidamente tensa y a veces
violenta y manifestantes anti vacuna le
lanzaron piedras a crudo sin embargo la
postura del candidato conservador eri no
tuvo contra las vacunas terminó
perjudicando le después de que el virus
empezara a hacer estragos en alberta
gobernada por los conservadores tras la
derrota o toole arremetió contra crudo
por haber convocado las elecciones y por
haber prometido convocar otra si los
liberales no obtenían la mayoría
y retó al primer ministro que anteponga
la unidad de este país y el bienestar de
su pueblo le dije que si cree que puede
amenazar con otras elecciones en 18
meses el partido conservador estará
preparado
al haberse esfumado el sueño de mantener
la mayoría en la cámara de los comunes
los liberales tendrán que volver a
apoyarse en la oposición con los nuevos
demócratas de tendencia izquierdista
para aprobar su plan de recuperación
fiscal tras la pandemia
en otras noticias desde nueva york el
ministro francés de asuntos exteriores
jean yves le drían al pidió de
explicaciones a eeuu por el pacto acuse
que cancela un millonario contrato de
desarrollo de submarinos franceses la
atención desde el diálogo sobre otros
temas en la asamblea general de la onu
que comienza oficialmente hoy en la
ciudad de nueva york entre los asuntos
de la agenda está en el manejo de la
pandemia el cambio climático y la
situación en afganistán
una reunión atípica después de que el
coi 19 obligó a los líderes mundiales el
año pasado a pronunciar sus discursos
desde la distancia en esta versión
aunque la asamblea general de la onu
tendrá delegaciones reducidas se espera
la presencia de más de 100 jefes de
estado y de gobierno la gestión de la
pandemia será uno de los ejes de la
reunión el secretario general de las
naciones unidas antonio guterres recalcó
la necesidad de revertir la desigualdad
en la distribución de las vacunas
mientras que el presidente de eeuu joe
biden promovió una reunión virtual con
los líderes mundiales para impulsar la
repartición hago un llamado al mundo
para que se movilicen detrás de un plan
de vacunación que duplique la producción
de vacunas para llegar al 70 por ciento
de la población mundial a mediados del
próximo año
otros de los temas principales es el
cambio climático el primer ministro
británico pidió que los países
desarrollados se comprometan con donar
100.000 millones de dólares anuales para
financiar las acciones climáticas en
países en vías de desarrollo
el mundo en vía de desarrollo es el que
está soportando la peor parte del cambio
climático en forma de huracanes
incendios e inundaciones
se prevé que la crisis en afganistán
también sea tratada para definir cómo
gestionar la situación del país y el
envío de ayuda humanitaria
la asamblea sea en medio de tensiones
que opacan las conversaciones que se
llevarán a cabo esta semana como la
crisis de confianza por el acuerdo
august entre estados unidos gran bretaña
y australia que dejó por fuera francia y
las relaciones entre china y eeuu a la
ejecuté res calificó de disfuncionales y
eeuu pidió a los haitianos a que no
emprendan el peligro son camino hacia su
país después de que más de 13 mil
migrantes cruzarán de forma irregular la
frontera desde méxico también la casa
blanca expresó su preocupación por un
vídeo que muestra a agentes de la
patrulla fronteriza a caballo
presuntamente usando látigos en contra
de los migrantes en la frontera sin
embargo continuaron las deportaciones y
ayer cientos de haitianos regresaron a
puerto príncipe tras ser deportados para
muchos eso significa regresar a un país
prácticamente
desconocido
con el sueño americano frustrado y de
regreso a un país que no está listo para
recibirlos en ese limbo se mueven
cientos de migrantes haitianos
deportados de eeuu muchos de ellos
abandonaron la nación hace años son
después del terremoto de 2010 y vuelven
a un lugar casi desconocido más pobres
violento e inestable que cuando se
marcharon ante la falta de oportunidades
de volver a emigrar es una posibilidad
pero si no me dan igual cuánto
públicamente
frente a la puerta de ahora no tengo
desde el domingo eeuu comenzó a expulsar
a cientos de inmigrantes que querían
ingresar irregularmente al país algunos
denuncian malos tratos
cuando llegamos a eeuu nos pusieron en
detención por cuatro días cuatro días
sin lavarnos los dientes sin ducharnos
solo nos dieron algo de comida como no
queríamos irnos en el bus y abordar el
avión nos encerraron para calmarnos
algunas mujeres fueron golpeadas ellos
golpearon a hombres y mujeres
a su llegada a las personas fueron
sometidas a controles administrativos y
pruebas pcr pero las autoridades
haitianas temen no poder asistir a los
recién llegados
el problema es que estas personas no
aceptan las deportaciones forzadas
porque esa es la razón por la que
dejaron haití no quieren vivir en haití
incluso si tuviéramos el centro mejor
equipado del mundo para recibirlos no lo
aceptarían porque para ellos haití es el
infierno tras una extensa y compleja
travesía estos migrantes vuelven al
casillero de salida con menos recursos y
más incertidumbre que antes
a continuación otras noticias que
destacamos para ustedes los talibanes
terminaron de formar su gabinete y
eligieron solo hombres pese a las
críticas tras presentar al núcleo duro
del gabinete todos igualmente hombres a
principios de este mes según el régimen
talibán la mayoría de estos
nombramientos se realizaron en base al
mérito
el tribunal europeo de derechos humanos
considera rusia responsable del
asesinato del ex espía y opositor
alexandr litvinenko envenenado con
polonio 210 en 2006 en reino unido
además la policía británica informó hoy
que tiene suficiente evidencia para
imputar a un tercer agente ruso por el
envenenamiento con novillo k un ex
agente ruso en inglaterra en 2018
el río de lava del volcán la cumbre
vieja ubicado en la isla española de la
palma se ocultó 166 viviendas más de
cinco mil quinientas personas fueron
evacuadas la aparición de una nueva boca
eruptiva obligado a cerrar cinco
carreteras de estadista
y en australia a cientos de personas se
manifestaran una ciudad de melbourne
protagonizando choques con la policía
luego de que las autoridades cerraron
los sitios de construcción diciendo que
el movimiento frecuente de trabajadores
estaba propagando el coronavirus nuestro
corresponsal en esa ciudad camilo
montoya con la información
la orden del gobierno de parar
totalmente la industria de la
construcción durante dos semanas
desencadenó la jornada de protestas en
melbourne cerca de 2000 personas
salieron a manifestarse en contra de
esta decisión dice el gobierno del
estado de victoria que tuvo que tomarla
porque la mitad de los sitios de
construcción inspeccionados no están
cumpliendo las normas sanitarias contra
el cob y 19 de hecho hay 443 casos
activos en 186 sitios de construcción
del gobierno por eso además ordenó que
desde el 23 de septiembre todos los
trabajadores de la industria deberán
tener al menos una dosis de la vacuna
por eso en medio de las protestas ellos
dicen que la vacuna debe ser algo
voluntario y no algo obligatorio las
protestas fueron en gran parte pacíficas
pero hubo también altercados
enfrentamientos violentos principalmente
con la policía en este parque en cartón
gardens hubo un ataque en contra de
varios vehículos de la policía dice
justamente la policía del estado de
victoria que hubo 44 arrestos un
periodista resultó herido al igual que
tres policías y también hubo numerosos
daños materiales en propiedades privadas
y también vehículos oficiales espera que
las protestas continúen en los próximos
días
de esta manera terminamos el informativo
continúa con nosotros buen día para
todos
[Música]